[Music]
welcome back we're still joined by
Democratic congressman Eric's wawel of
California member of the House in
telling you were watching cable news for
the past year no doubt you have seen the
congressman talking a lot about Russia
there's part Russia attacked our
democracy this past election and then
they showed up to his Trump Tower
offered the evidence to his family they
received it they didn't they didn't turn
it down Donald Trump for years had been
working with the Russians he brought
people on his campaign who had ties to
the Russians we have seen a candidate
and a president who has spoken in very
flattering ways about Vladimir Putin all
of the arrows continue to point to a
personal political and financial
relationship that Donald Trump had with
the Russians the congressman is come on
tonight we've given him a lot of time to
present to us evidence actual evidence
of collusion congressman thanks a lot
for coming back of course not so there
you know Trump said of the campaign I
want to bring us closer to Russia a lot
of people agree I certainly agree with
that a lot of people on his campaign why
why did you agree with that because
there's a geopolitical matter I think
the enemy is China and I and I think we
have we have more than one mm back sure
absolutely but I just think it's I don't
agree with her posture aggressive but I
don't agree the trouble ministration is
posture toward Russia right now actually
it's too bellicose whatever but that's a
legitimate point it's all I'm saying it
doesn't make you a traitor but is there
actual evidence where's the I've what
fault is pretty carefully where's the
actual evidence of collusion between the
Trump campaign and Putin so 20 14 15 16
Russians hack into our DNC they
weaponize social media 2015 they make
what I think is the first approach that
we know so Felix a der Russian American
former business partner with Donald
Trump approaches Donald Trump's lawyer
Michael Cohen and says let's get Donald
Trump to build a Trump Tower in Moscow
right we can engineer this get Trump and
Putin together and make our boy
president so that's the first known
approach so the hacking is going on you
start to see these different approaches
and there's two different types of
approaches
there's the approaches to get Trump and
Putin together which is unusual because
he's a candidate and then there's the
approaches to preview the hacked emails
that the Russians have against Hillary
Clinton so you see that offer made to
George
right while he's over in London by a
Russian he lied about that he pled
guilty to lying admitted that it
occurred you see the approach with the
June 9th meeting the aguillera family
Russian developers close to Putin trying
to get Trump and Putin together they
offer you no dirt on Hillary Clinton
that June 9th meeting they move heaven
and earth Donald Trump jr. and Paul
Manafort and Kushner to take the meeting
right Donald Trump days before the
meeting occurred once his son knows the
meetings happening tells the world new
informations coming out about Hillary
Clinton days after the meeting Julian
Assange tells the world that Hillary
Clinton emails are coming out then you
start to see the hacked emails released
what does candidate Trump do he doesn't
disavow them no one in the family says
we had taken these meetings instead he
invites the Russians on a public stage
to hackmore so I asked him you're
talking about him an invitation he he
did so I think we we have that this is
July 27th 2016 at the doral National
which he owns in Doral Florida here here
here's the clip you're talking about
Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the 30,000 emails that are
missing I think you will probably be
rewarded mightily by our press let's see
if that happens
oh yeah two questions he was rewarded
one do we have the 30,000 emails did
Russia ever come up with those we're
still I know that what we haven't seen
them yeah let's let the molar
investigation continue okay maybe Muller
is in contact with the Russians but but
Trump didn't come up with those from the
Russians so this happened but let me yes
if Trump was that are still an attempt
there right okay what did you do I mean
I hate to inject common sense into this
what you do in broad day we can make
secret contact with Russia your handlers
back in Moscow wouldn't you dial them up
on the shortwave in the basement would
you really send a coded message in the
middle of a joke at a press conference
I'm not saying he's the smartest guy in
the world Tucker never accused about
that what that's that's the sort of
you've gotten right that's part of the
evidence an invitation made by the
candidate at a pile intimates okay okay
but
okay so he's both a secret agent for
Putin but he's so dumb that he spills
the secrets at a press conference on TV
the latter okay so he makes that
invitation he doesn't disavow what
they're doing but so what do they do
they start to do more give him the
30,000 emails they start to do more they
start to hack more and so you heard the
people laughing at the end of what he
said right he's broadcasting he's
committing you know that if a 30 day
light show
why wouldn't he just act through all the
many Russian agents let me continue so
at the same time those are fair
questions right a little confusing boy a
fair question so what's the answer but
there's no hey what do you do it in
public why did he admit to Lester Holt
obstruction of justice in public there's
no who could be so stupid they commit
the crime in public exception he did as
any secret agent ever broadcast a
message at a press conference to his
handlers ever has any businessman ever
been elected president sometimes you're
the first person to do it so Tucker
again
he made the invitation makes the
invitation of public right then you
start to see during the summer of 2016
these 'man we have an email that is
titled Kremlin connection an offer made
to Paul Erickson of the campaign to
connect Donald Trump and vitamin Putin
again okay Kremlin connection right so
again more did they connect first do we
have evidence that he I don't believe it
they connected but again where's the
evidence the evidence
well first Tucker don't confuse evidence
with a conclusion evidence gives the FBI
and the Department of Justice look I
watch Rachel Maddow I get it I know
there are a lot of Russians and Russian
people and emails but like where's the
actual proof that something happened
after more than a year of this well not
have any prosecutor I don't have
subpoena power
Bob Moeller does all I'm saying he was a
high-level security clearance and you're
on the Intel committee so presumably
you'd have more than like a clip of him
added I'm only giving you the evidence
that I've seen in an unclassified manner
so I'm telling you that all of that
warrants looking at whether we could
prove beyond a reasonable doubt
conspiracy to defraud the United States
those other things working on that I
mean we've been working well a lot of
for a long time not with the obstruction
that we continue to see the continued
undermining the trying to that's it
that's all you got no no no okay so
what's the part I haven't heard tell me
I'm waiting because I
look if he's it's right in front of your
nose Tucker tell me what it's easier
with more secret messages or tell me
again tiger when we look back on this in
25 years we're gonna be amazed at how
much of it was right in front of us so
they're hacking there's a Chinese at
that point there's no people thought
Russia was the threat isn't that weird
there's approaches they never turn down
any of the approaches the candidate
makes an invitation in broad daylight as
you see they continue to try and arrange
meetings through the summer and then you
start to have what I call you know the
quiff there's a quid pro quo there has
to be a quo right if there's a
transaction that's taking place you
start that of course there's the
candidates positive favorable statements
about Putin even if those are just as
you said so we have a better
relationship with Russia how do you
explain the National Security Adviser
the incoming National Security Advisor
Michael Flynn who had been over to
Russia just a year before telling the
Russians don't worry about the Barack
Obama imposed sanctions yeah how do you
explain that that's bringing the
Russians into the Oval Office giving
them massive shared hope that we would
stop with the sanctions on Russia I
think they're kind of productive but the
Trump administration has done just the
opposite so we spent javelin missiles to
the Ukrainian rebels we've opened up
domestic oil production here which hurts
them in gas production we have killed
over 200 Russians in Syria we have
bombed the government of Bashar al-assad
which is their closest ally outside
their borders in what sense has he been
Pro Russia as president and I say this
with sadness because I don't think I
should be doing any of that well all the
favorable things that he says bringing
Russians into the Oval Office kicking
out Americans letting Russian press
really quick failure to impose that
congressionally past sanctions you know
how hard we had to work the public
sentiment that was about killing the 200
Russians he's been did he kill her
he sent the US military I don't you
idiot too much credit I don't know he's
look I'm not flacking her Trump he's I
don't think he should have done it I
criticized I know you did you know
you're absolutely I'm just telling you
he's killed 200 Russians Obama did not
do that
he sent missiles to Ukrainian rebels
Obama did not do that he is competing in
energy with them in a way Obama never
tried why is he more pro-russian that
Obama was don't confuse what he has to
do because the public sentiment is so
high and watching
you didn't touch credit you're getting
too much giving him credit I'm sizing I
don't think you should be doing any a
good I'm just saying this whole thing is
insane that's what I'm saying so and
then you have all the consciousness of
consciousness of guilt evidence right
all of the lies that have been told
whether is about the June 9th meeting
the Russian adoption excuse and then
moving it right out what it was really
about okay so that's that's conscious of
guilt a lot of times the way someone
acts after an investigation is launched
can tell you what they were I guess I'm
not you know what I'm not going in voice
maybe don't go don't go with the
conclusion there's more than enough
evidence to continue and find out how
close for these ties did the willingness
I was hoping for some